[Musik]
und damit herzlich willkommen ja heute
zu einem neuen video auf einem kanal
meine lieben freunde ich glaube mehr
kritisch kann eine begrüßung nicht sein
allerdings ist ja bereits im titel und
zwar reagiere ich heute mal wieder auf
einige gerüchte die ihr mir bei
instagram geschickt habt auf instagram
herzlich laser luca so schaut da gern
mal vorbei falls ihr demnächst auch teil
meines neuen videos sein wollt und das
hier ist das erste gerücht von dem
lieben user 0 unterstrich mail expo
unterstrichen 0 du würdest rauchen
ich bin der größte anti raucher auf der
welt ich muss allerdings ehrlich gesagt
zu geben das sich mit 18 oder 19 auf 12
mal an der zigarette gezogen habe weil
es einfach probieren wollte allerdings
ich habe es gehasst und luisa
unterstrich eso behauptet du riechst gut
also ich habe heute morgen geduscht von
daher würde ich schon nächstes gerücht
dass deine zähne gebiet sind ich habe
meine zähne noch nie blicken lassen und
ich bin auch so unfassbar ungern und
sehr sehr sehr sehr selten beim zahnarzt
weiß da über alles hasse allerdings
liegt glaube ich einfach daran dass mit
zahnpflege sehr wichtig ist so ich putze
mir dreimal am tag die zähne und ich
rauche nicht ich trinke keinen kaffee
und ist keine schokolade
also ja das leben tutorials mit
lucarelli unterstrich 17 26 80 schreibt
luca pizza 4
di luca pizza 3 ist seit zwei wochen
raus und du fragst mich nach der luca
pizza vier alte sehen wir sonst hätten
wir sonst nichts zu tun
wer also real talk wir sind gerade noch
voll happy dass das mit der luca pizza
drei alles geklappt hat jetzt zum ersten
zwölfter und haben machen uns gerade
eigentlich noch gar nicht so richtig
gedanken über luca pizza vier allerdings
wird denke ich schon eine combo
unterstrich unterstrichen mark
unterstrich baums wie auch immer hier
auf diese namen kommt schreibt auf jeden
fall dass du ein lauf bist unterstrich
israel unterstrich schreibt du bist
millionär ja ich bin millionär halt die
fresse du laden kevin crew ist die beste
schreibt du bist dummen also um die
frage ernsthaft zu beantworten ich habe
mein abi gemacht und ich habe mein
studium mit irgendwie 1,7 oder so
abgeschlossen also so auf den kopf
gefallen bin ich glaube ich nicht
allerdings schalte ich manchmal nicht so
schnell und ich bin absolut nicht
multitaskingfähig und ich bin komplett
tollpatsch also eigentlich bin ich schon
ziemlich dumm wie hash 02 schreibt
sandra ist deine tochter
ja ja besonders meine tochter zero
killer 0 1 hat gehört dass ich gras
rauchen uhr christmette auf daniel talk
ich habe schon mal gras geraucht und
zwar auch irgendwie vor 45 jahren oder
so in amsterdam also das ist ja legal
dass man dort marihuana raucht aber auch
da bin ich kein fan von also ich bin
wirklich wenn nicht mit drogen nehme
dann ist es die legale droge alkohol ab
und zu am wochenende
aber kinder haltet die finger weg von
drogen wirklich mehr alle punkt m
unterstrich b sagt du bist übels
arrogant du hast auch ganz falsch
geschrieben also auch da muss ich wieder
sagen real tag es gibt definitiv sehr
viele leute die denken dass ich arrogant
bin und ich glaube gerade diese klubs
sache hat das ganze auch nicht
befürwortet aber muss ich auch ganz
ehrlich sagen und da werden jetzt
bestimmt auch wieder heute sagen das ist
arrogant ist aber es juckt mich ein
scheiß was irgendwelche leute über mich
denken so mich juckt es definitiv krass
was freunde über mich sagen oder familie
oder keine ahnung was das nehme ich noch
echt zu herzen aber wenn dann internet
leute schreiben die mich nicht mal
kennen und dann ich habe da sollte man
sich nicht viel viel von machen und ich
glaube egal ob man jetzt großen
öffentlichkeit steht oder ob man einfach
nur ja privaten foto hochlädt lasst euch
nichts von irgendwelchen anderen leuten
sagen macht euer ding hört auf eure
freunde eure familien das ist der beste
rat immer einen geben kann wendet
hattest du schon mal was mit einem
zuschauer fragt ansgar edgar nein noch
nie ich kann es mir auch ehrlich gesagt
nicht vorstellen also klar wenn ich
jetzt so die liebe meines lebens finden
würde dann würde es mir irgendwie beim
dritten date sagen ich hab früher einmal
deine videos geschaut ich voll gefeiert
haben im märz zu hause dann will ich
jetzt nicht sagen okay so nach dem motto
aber es ich würde es niemals zu machen
wie weit sie nicht so soll jol i miss
you got so weiter dass du in love with
me bis behauptet anja punkt lanz nein
ich bin grad mit niemandem auf xx alina
unterstrich lea xx behauptet du bist
nicht mehr mit jule zusammen ja also
also nein wir sind nicht mehr zusammen
also
hätte diese fragen wo man nicht weiß ob
man mit ja oder nein antworten soll wenn
man nicht weiß wie es richtig formuliert
ist ich bin auf jeden fall seit einiger
zeit nicht mehr mit jude zusammen
eventuell habt ihr den bei den beitrag
auf instagram dass ich hab ein schwarzes
foto gepostet sehr gut luca will und ich
habe auf unseren instagram profilen ein
bild gepostet mit dem text runter warum
wir uns getrennt haben aber wir sind
noch voll gute freunde beschreiben
tägliche und möchten einfach dass das so
ein bisschen loki bleibt wir wollen
jetzt kein video machen zum wegen warum
wir uns getrennt haben oder so wir
wollen das nicht verschaukeln als das
ist ein wir beide schon mehr oder
weniger genug unter der trennung leiden
und ja also ich bin nicht mehr im juli
zusammen das gerücht stimmt auf jeden
fall beziehungsweise ist halt kein
gerücht aber ja also ich bin single und
julia auch alex die 242 behauptet dass
du mit max streit hass nein das f das
ist auch so eine sache die wird uns
irgendwie immer geschrieben oder nahe
gelegt so nach dem motto und in die
kommentare gehauen von wissen ja die
beiden haben streit und auf luca mit
seppl und deswegen machen sie nichts
nein wir haben es einfach so ein
bisschen auseinander gelebt aber haben
uns letztens tatsächlich mal wieder
getroffen die tage waren zusammen
trinken und vielleicht kommt bald wieder
war julia happy horse schreibt dass du
mit sandra zusammen werden wo hörten ihr
diese scheiße immer jule ist schwanger
nein
also ich bin weder noch in einer
beziehung mit jude noch ist sie
schwanger sarah unterstrich k 366 frage
siehst du ende 2019 jetzt nach hamburg
oder nicht das ist zwar kein gerücht
sondern eine frage aber um die frage zu
beantworten ja ich werde noch nach
hamburg ziehen allerdings werde ich die
wohnung hier in köln gehalten und dann
werde ich immer so ein bisschen pendeln
mehr oder weniger der hauptgrund für
hamburg war ja eigentlich wegen jule
weil sie die stadt sogar mark und
familie und so weiter und so fort ich
mag hamburg auch gerne ob die stadt ins
herz geschlossen und werde aber köln
behalten und immer so ein bisschen
pendeln du hast jule mit katja und bibi
betrogen schreibt leo pr trooper
und auch noch mit daggi dass du schwul
bist mache keinen sinn darin mit jule
zusammen war es trotzdem oft gelesen
behaupteten dominik h lskn pr komischer
name aber nein ich bin nicht schwul aber
ja ich habe auch schon sehr sehr häufig
gelesen dass ich schwul bin aber ich bin
nicht schwul
also es ist ja nicht stimmen schwul zu
sein aber ich bin halt nicht wo ich bin
hetero und ich war ja auch mit jude
jetzt bis vor kurzem noch zusammen tube
locker schreibt dass du wenn du weißt
eine kamera filmte ich zum beispiel dass
du dich versteckst ich glaube dass net
sprachen lernen also ich glaube sie
meint dass wenn hier eine kamera an
lässt sich eher so bin so hey leute was
geht herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video und dann aufnahme ende
ich bin zweiter mein geld zählen auch
darum die frage rialto quad zu
beantworten ja in einer gewissen form
klar bin ich aufgedrehter wenn die
kamera an ist und wenn mich in dieser
fette lichter an leuchten und das haben
wir auch oft schon leute gesagt nicht
auf der straße getroffen haben die
meinten dann immer so herr dein video
ist immer so voll aufgedreht aber hier
bist du voll entspannt cool man kann
diesen vor locker mit ihr unterhalten
wir dachten es vielmehr so aber ja also
ich bin auf jeden fall ein bisschen
energiegeladene und hyperaktiver wenn
kameras aber jetzt verstellen also ich
glaube wenn man sich vorstellt hat man
nicht erfolg wenn man mit sich selbst
vor dass andere einen krasseren bizeps
als du hast
nee nee 442 schreibt dass du ein kind
hast was wir hörten ihr das als wenn ich
nur ein geht habe ich habe 430 juli zeh
ja also ich mag döner sehr gern ich will
jetzt nicht jeden zweiten tag da aber so
ein mal die woche und döner 5 geht schon
klar rolle punkt 04 schreibt dass du
julia boutiques geküsst hast nein nein
also ich war vier tage mit julia auf dem
dreh in eschwege mitten in deutschland
im niemandsland
wir haben gedreht für die bundespolizei
das video kommt irgendwann im januar
online also dauert noch im monat aber
wir haben nur zusammen da halt gedreht
diese ganzen sachen her mg unterstrich
niki schreibt dass du deine freunde nur
als vorzeige bild hast also nur aus
youtube gründen nein das hat doch das
ding so ich hatte vor allem nur aus
youtube gründen sie hat doch julia hat
ja nichtmal youtube gemacht du hast im
bootshaus einen tisch kaputt gemacht
weil keine ahnung ich glaub nicht aber
wenn ich es gemacht habe dann weiß ich
wer du bist reich kommt immer darauf an
wie man reich definiert also ich finde
reiche jetzt bezogen aufs geld muss man
halt ganz klar sagen wenn man seine
miete bezahlen kann und wenn man sein
essen und trinken und alles möglich
bezahlen kann was halt so anfällt und
dann noch geld und ob hat dann ist man
eigentlich reich finde ich also man muss
es genauer definieren dass du kino heißt
mit zweitnamen behauptet 44 punkt ja
ickx und ja das stimmt
ich bin nicht so stolz auf diesen
zweiten namen aber ich heiße team mit
zwei lese überall irgendwie dass du voll
der alkoholiker bist ja das kommt
wahrscheinlich wegen dem podcast von
sandra und mir also falls jetzt noch
nicht wusste und ich glaube das weiß
eigentlich jeder andere und ich habe
einen podcast wo wöchentlich immer
donnerstags eine dreiviertel stunden
lange folge erscheint und wir trinken
während der folge immer ein bierchen
fest entspannter atmosphäre ist und
vielleicht denken deswegen einige dass
ich alkoholiker bin aber nein
also ich trinke genauso viel wie andere
störten auch so einmal die woche oder
alle zwei wochen dass du einen porsche
kern bestellt hast ja das stimmt
tatsächlich
das ist ein elektroauto von porsche und
aber der kommt bald zurück in die garage
gefahren autor umfang
ja ich will allerdings das heutige video
endet meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann würde ich mich auf
jeden fall sehr darüber einen daumen
hoch von euch oder video freuen ich habe
mich geschnitten beim rasieren obwohl
ich kein bart ab das muss man erstmal
schaffen schreibt mir gern weitere
gerüchte die über mich schon mal gehört
habt und in die kommentare dann werde
ich auf ein paar eingehen und das
versuchen auch noch aus dem weg zu
schaffen beziehungsweise euch dann rede
und antwort zu stehen im vollen lauf
instagram ich heißt der laser luca
abonniert main kanal hier auf youtube
zeigt auf die glocke hier auf youtube
bekommen benachrichtigen wenn neue
anleihen gehen jetzt kommt raus
[Musik]